javascript is one of the most popular
programming languages in the world right
now
but is it useful for data scientists to
take the time required to learn it
keep watching and we'll discuss this i'm
richard and this is richard undata
so hopefully some of you have seen my
video on a study pathway for
up-and-coming data scientists
basically i recommend before anything
else learn
sql then pick either one of r or python
and master it later on you can go back
take the other one
and learn enough to be dangerous then
some of you may be seeing my videos on
sas and power bi where i talk about the
future of these technologies
and whether or not your standard
run-of-the-mill data scientist
should invest time into learning those
whenever i make one of these videos i
get a mix of both
interest and trolls and i enjoy both of
those things so i figured why not i'll
make a video about javascript too
now if you've seen those videos you know
the sorts of things that i'm going to
talk about
but if you haven't i'm going to overview
them before we get started
first i'm going to talk about what
javascript even is in the first place
then based on whatever available metrics
i can find
i'm going to talk about how popular it
is both at large
and then specifically in the data
science community i'll talk about
using my own experience as a guiding
factor here
how easy or difficult that it is to
learn and then i'll talk about some of
the use cases that data scientists might
find for it
there's way too much pressure out there
in the data science community to learn
lots and lots of different technologies
so i'm going to end with some factors
that will help
you decide whether it's worth taking the
time and investment to learn javascript
before i do all of that though take a
moment to hit the like button to this
video for the youtube algorithm
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and hit the notification bell
that way youtube will notify you
whenever i make a video
and then lastly i'll have a link to my
patreon account in the description of
this video
and if you guys would be willing to
support me over that way it would be
massively
massively appreciated alright so to be
perfectly honest
javascript probably doesn't require any
introduction at
all but i'm going to try to provide one
anyway
javascript has been around since 1995
and alongside html and css it's one of
the primary scripting languages behind
the internet as a whole
the trademark of it is owned by oracle
but the language is defined by an
organization called the european
computer manufacturers association
or ecma it's an object oriented language
that's generally compiled
just in time and it's dynamically typed
although because it's defined by the
ecma
script language standard it's not open
source
and then probably the most common way
that it's used is through
node which is a command line interpreter
using that
you can make use of npm that is the node
package manager
to install and use javascript libraries
now the contrast with html and css is
that while those two things
typically drive the structure behind a
web page
javascript's claim to fame is its
ability to drive the interactive
elements behind web pages
and there's a little bit of confusion
and sort of an assumption that it's
closely related to java
just because of the name but java is a
completely different thing
and it's totally out of the scope of
this video anyway the many others are
probably familiar with jsons
that is javascript object notation which
is a pretty common way
of storing objects through attribute
value pairing
now as we talk about how popular
javascript is in general
the simple answer to that is extremely
as of december 2020 anyway javascript is
number seven
on the tyobi index now this index is
defined by how much it's pinged on
various search engines out there
so of course this isn't a perfect metric
by any stretch of the imagination
but out of all the languages that the
tai hobi index
tracks javascript enjoys 2.35
of the search results on all of them and
this isn't an apples and oranges
comparison at
all least of all because of how much
they're used for data science purposes
varies massively but javascript is far
behind python
though at least right now it does enjoy
a very comfortable lead over r
that's wonderful and everything but the
real question that you should be asking
is how much is it used for data science
specifically i couldn't find any job
reports on it
but there is one specific finding from
the 2020 state of data science report
from anaconda
that's worth pointing out basically they
conducted a large
multinational survey of data science
professionals
and asked how often they use various
languages
they found that 91 percent of people at
least sometimes use python
then there's a big drop-off to 47
percent of people
that at least sometimes use r then
there's another drop-off to
35 percent of people that at least
sometimes use javascript
so i think it's fair to conclude the
following it's not
the most popular programming language in
the world at least in the data science
community
but the chances that you're going to end
up running into it or having to use it
for some reason
are significantly greater than zero that
holds true for me
personally as well more on that later
but you're probably also wondering how
difficult it is to learn
and my simple answer to that would be
out of all the programming languages out
there
it's right up there with python as one
of the absolute easiest to learn
javascript is the first programming
language of choice for quite a lot of
people
and i think it's a very gentle
introduction to the nuances and
challenges that come with coding in
general
if you're somebody who's coming from an
r or python background as i imagine a
lot of my viewing audience is
you're going to find it syntactically
very similar to python
in part due to the object-oriented
nature of both of these languages
ultimately python and javascript do have
a lot of differences
and completely separate use cases but i
will provide in the description of this
video
some resources for learning javascript
through w3schools and through codecademy
i think both of these are awesome all
those resources are free
and if you go through all of them it'll
probably take you about 30 hours of time
but after the fact you're gonna have a
pretty reasonable handle on the language
and be ready to try some real world
projects for a programming language
that's not too bad
in addition there's a book out there
called javascript for data science
it was written by a lot of different
authors it's totally free
and it was obviously written with the
data community in mind that'll also be
in the description
so now that we've established how hard
it is to learn there's a perfectly
natural follow-up question to ask
which is what are the specific use cases
of javascript for
data science in particular you probably
want to know
what the special packages in the
javascript ecosystem
are out there for data science and then
why you would want to use those
instead of the traditional juggernauts
of r or python
so i'm going to actually start this one
off with a personal experience
which is that i missed out on the
opportunity to be involved with a
prospective client opportunity
because i lacked the required experience
with javascript
but specifically with the visualization
library d3
the focus of the d3 library is on
interactive visualization
and there's no question about it the
package is outstanding
considering javascript's primary focus
is on the interactive qualities of web
development
let's just say that this thing is going
to run circles around your standard
visualization libraries in r or python
even if you're making use of the plotly
api i'll have a link in the description
to a big d3 gallery in case you don't
believe me
and there's several other javascript
packages out there that stand out to me
as serving huge
purpose in the data science world for
example we've got things like
nlp.js ml.js
and tensorflow.js the use case for all
those things should be fairly
self-explanatory
then just generally speaking let's
suppose you work in an organization with
very heavily javascript based
products and services and you have to
work pretty closely with software
developers
then yeah obviously being able to read
and write the same language
is going to be highly beneficial but
obviously and you knew this was where i
was going
there are catches and reasons why
javascript might not be something you
want to invest your time in
as a data scientist now the reason i do
videos like this in the first place
is because you can only learn so many
things if you try to learn too much you
end up spreading yourself way too thin
and you end up learning nothing and time
that you spend learning javascript
is time that you're not growing your
skills in python or machine learning or
whatever else you're interested in
and here's the key thing while it's
obviously
totally plausible to use javascript for
data science
that's also totally not what the
language was designed for
compare that with python which is a
general purpose programming language
with
years and years of data science specific
development
or r which was built by statisticians
for other statisticians and the fact
that python and r
are so dominant in the data science
sphere really is meaningful
particularly when you go about building
innovative solutions
and you need to do a little bit of
google or stack overflow
consultation honestly that alone makes
it difficult for any language whether
that's
julia or javascript or anything else
to compete with those two on one hand
you have less mature data science
packages already developed
and when you need to go google something
you have less of a chance of finding the
answer to your question
again because not as many people are
using the language for that same purpose
now in the case of julia you have a lot
of performance qualities going for it
and then with javascript you have the
amazing visualization capabilities
as well as the ability to collaborate
more effectively in
organizations that are primarily
javascript development shops
but overall and i'll say it again i
think what makes sense for the majority
of people
is to learn one of r or python first
master it and then go back to the other
one and learn enough to be dangerous
and after that and assuming you have a
solid foundation in things like linear
algebra
machine learning and good communication
skills
i think javascript could make a lot of
sense to learn
but go into it knowing exactly why you
want to learn it
and what types of use cases you have for
it so thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it please consider
sharing it hit the like button
and then let me know what you think do
you agree do you disagree
let me know in the comments then i'll
see you all in the not so distant future
until then richard on data